bill s 201 on
genetic discrimination was supposed to
pass soon after the start of the new
year
but this bill is delayed we feel here
the government of justin trudeau
wavering on the basis that he would not have
the jurisdiction to act  in the face of the powerful
lobby of insurance companies
that approached
parliament
pierre thibault and assistant dean and
secretary of the civil law section
of the faculty of law at the university
of ottawa
he is also a member of the committee of
senate experts on the famous bill
factors on the one hand we have jurisdiction in
federal law in criminal law and on
the other hand it is likely that
they played but be careful what you are
doing there by this bill  law there it
affects cash the field of
contracts is a field which falls under prices
and the field of france which
also falls under progress so the debate
takes place at two levels
the federal parliament key gifi by virtue
of its power in law  criminal and
I am one of those who think that it is
an exercise will read that the fact of
touching contracts and the field
of insurance and incidental to the exercise
of the federal parliament including the three
provinces in question and the companies
insurance companies say no no it touches
no angle the jurisdiction of the provinces
in terms of contracts and france and
finally the river had to remove these
provisions from other projects obviously
the companies the brakes came from
wines different committees whether it is in the
chamber of  common in the senate for this
for the day strong bill that the
dhafra campaigns reject no more
countries where they do not want to be drafted
to require screening tests and
medicine their exit ottawa prefer
therefore to criminalize the request
for genetic information
from  people other than doctors
or caregivers is really a strong
push patient groups to get
this law passed now
will it complete  t solved the problem
once the law is going to be given a chance
on a little less certain there is a
pretty is an associate professor at the center of
genomics and policy
at mcgill university in montreal
so how do we  I am
in full field of competence which
belongs to us not good what they have found
as a solution is to criminalize the
fact for people outside the
therapeutic relationship so are not
doctors or caregivers to ask for
genetic information so
will it work or not we
often have ccd law after which we precisely
there are problems of
constitutionality the provinces want to
sue so false it remains to be seen
question of discrimination on the
basis of  dna comes back regularly in
canada is more and more frequently
i people who pass simple
screening tests at the request of
their doctor, for example
the seven members because i would
like my children  nts i have a
24 year old girl then a 17 year old boy i
would like he i would also like to have
genetic tests to see if they
are carriers of cancer young
a while ago botello links life in
2014 had survived  breast cancer
this mother in her
forties is worried about her children
and then the part is that these
results are used by
insurance companies because they are still
young they are not insured and
fear and that if they make a request to the
insurance company that they
be refused or that they are asked to
pay an additional premium the association of
canadian companies
affirms that the insurance companies
request the  results of a
genetic test only if the client has
already undergone one of his own accord
just as she asks to be made
aware of any health problem
there is nothing less the association
adds that if  companies are now
asking for  s very high premiums for
people who are at risk of genetic diseases
these courses simply reflect
the importance of the
responsibility that
insurance companies accept does not require testing
but we need this information
claude di stasio vice  president
quebec affairs of the canadian association
of life and health insurance companies
if we were forbidden any information
with genetic connotation we could not
spread out the antecedents of people and
that would have repercussions on the
value of france for
everyone  is not to be excluded these people it is to
assess the risks 95%
the applications are accepted the 5%
that we refuse it's not it's us
sometimes we come back with an additional premium
it's the individual that we refuse  wants without law
truly large-scale federal framework
Canadians sick or not will
almost always be on their
own so against
the insurance goliaths at the so-called convent a
repo  rtage of radio canada international